sorcières chauve-souris morts-vivants
tenté ce mercredi 1er novembre la ville
des clayes-sous-bois pour participer à
ce premier trailer in une course à pied
au départ du parc jean carré y ont
imaginé par les organisateurs depuis le
mois de janvier dernier sur cette date
il y avait peu de courses dans la région
donc là comme yavé rien je me suis dit
mais pourquoi pas me glisser sur 7 sur
cette date du 1er novembre et ensuite le
trail il déduit trahi le wind pour faire
un petit clin d'oeil à halloween
les deux sources à cette course
terrifiante proposé de la marche
nordique et des courses de 10 et 18 km à
travers les bois
un programme qui a séduit plus de 450
âmes perdues sur cette première édition
on a fait mal aux minières soir ça nous
empêche pas de fêter et puis on vient on
vient sans aucune appréhension à faire
18 tranquillement sort pas de problème
super idée on est un nom mais super et
thématique c'est top non franchement
c'est très très bonne idée on est hyper
content d'être là malgré la horde de
monstres qui l'entouré pendant la course
christophe deprez a eu le coeur
solidement accroché pour remporter le 10
km en 39 minutes et 30 secondes
c'est vrai qu'il faut gérer entre les
côtes le plat mois que je suis plus
qu'un de route donc le plat malien les
côtes
un peu plus dur mais bon on a eu deux ou
trois quatre derniers kilomètres
finir une fois l'apocalypse de la course
passé la matinée c'est évidemment
terminée par une dégustation d'une
potion à base de potiron
rendez vous l'année prochaine pour une
deuxième édition de ce trailer in
cauchemardesque
[Musique]